lady Dunnellon it's my privilege this
time in the absence of mr. William
DeMille to present to you mr. Louie be
mayor mr. mayor is the gentleman who
originally conceived the idea of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences was through his hard work and
earnest efforts this great organization
has come into being mr. mayor is also
the vice president of
metro-goldwyn-mayer whose artists won
three of the first Awards of the Academy
this year mr. mayor has something very
interesting to say to you and will they
to present an award to one of the
winners it's a great pleasure that I
introduce mr. mayor
ladies and gentlemen I'm about to
introduce to you a gentleman that while
he is a very dear friend of mine is also
a very strong competitor for this honor
and I'm going to call him out here that
you may have a good look at him and then
I will have much more to say mr. Lemle I
want to present to you mr. Carl Laemmle
who is a real pioneer in the art of
motion pictures as well as the president
of the universal film corporation whose
company produced that marvelous
production All Quiet on the Western
Front which the Academy has privileged
me to bestow upon mr. Lemle
through their vote that that's the
picture they acclaim as the greatest
achievement for the year I might also
add mr. Lemle that many of the great
writers in magazines have asked this
picture received the nobel peace prize
of the year and it's with a great
pleasure that I give you this
presentation of the bronze statuette
which is an indication that the Academy
as well as the entire industry consider
that you've produced a real epic and
finest evening Thank You mr. mayor
for this I knew how to express what is
in here but I just cannot do it next to
my becoming a grandfather this position
this is probably the proudest moment of
my whole life I want to take this
opportunity to thank you thank you to
thank the Academy of Motion Picture
science arts and sciences and to thank
every member and I also want to take
this opportunity of thanking our own
organization for having Khitan the world
that will be remembered for a long long
time thank you again while sorry I
didn't win it mr. Lemle I know no one
else I'd rather have beat me than you
thanks very much
friends I'm about to present this award
to a person who's very well known to you
I'm going to ask her to come out and
meet you miss Norma Shearer Norma I have
already briefly outlined to these ladies
and gentlemen the manner in which we
bestow these awards I'm going to repeat
for your benefit but you were nominated
by the actors branch of the Academy in
other words by your fellow players to
receive this award for the outstanding
performance by an actress for the past
year because of your fine work in the
divorcee this nomination made by the
actors branch was later voted on by the
entire membership of the Academy
consisting of seven or eight hundred
active persons in the motion picture
industry and it is their will that you
receive this award for the outstanding
performance by an actress for the year
1934 your work in the divorcee yeah
thank you I'm very thankful to my fellow
workers for the great honor of their
bestowed upon me in taking this award I
feel I'm sharing it with the directors
and the writers and the fellow actors
whose encouragement made possible
whatever degree of success I may have a
team I should like to uphold the
position of my sex but for once a woman
is a loss for words to tell you just
what this statue means to me in
encouragement inspiration and gratitude
thank you Norma
friends the members of the Academy have
decided that the big house is the
outstanding writing achievement for the
past year the author of the big house is
Miss Frances Marion who will now receive
the award from the hands of mr. Jack
Cunningham an outstanding member of the
Writers branch of the Academy I have the
honor of introducing mr. Jack Cunningham
jack folks I want to introduce to you a
very dear friend miss Francis Marion
Francis as the representative of the
writers branch of the Academy it gives
me great pleasure to present this award
to you all the more so because it was an
original story written direct for the
talking screen and not the adaptation of
a play or a novel thank you very much
friends I'm sorry that a number of the
winners of the awards cannot be with us
here to meet you and speak with you
personally but I'm sure you'd be
interested in knowing who the rest of
them are mr. George Arliss received the
award of merit for the outstanding
performance given by an actor for his
work in Disraeli and the Green Goddess
mr. Lewis milestone the director of All
Quiet on the Western Front was given the
award for the outstanding achievement in
Direction the outstanding production of
course you've already heard was all
Quiet on the Western Front for which mr.
Lemle received the award the greatest
achievement in cinema photography was
given for with bird at the South Pole
which is photographed by mr. William van
Devere and Joseph T Rucker jointly the
cameraman considered this one of the
greatest achievements in photography but
the world has ever known
the physical difficulties and the great
handicaps under which they worked only
added to the glory of the achievement
the greatest achievement in sound
recording was also awarded to the big
house the award will be given to the
sound Department of the
metro-goldwyn-mayer studio the finest
art direction of the year was awarded to
the king of jazz a universal production
and the work was done by mr. Herman Ross
I think this concludes the list of
awards and one of the greatest functions
of the Academy draws to a close for the
past year
thank you very much